(crowd cheering)
- Hello, hello, hello, hello, hello.
Hey, guys, how are you?
How are you?
Answer questions, so if you have one
it's good time to, uh, raise your hand.
Good.
I don't know who has
Pick, you pick.
You pick.
- [Male Speaker] I agree.
- Awesome.
- [Male Speaker] Hey,
Gary, how's it going?
- Good, man, what's your name?
- My name's Will, this is my wife Alissa.
Here's my question:
if you could have a sit down with anyone
from history or fictional,
who would it be?
- Randy The Macho Man Savage.
(audience cheers)
I mean he really, legitimately, like
obviously honestly, the honest real answer
to that question is I lost
both of my grandfathers
before I got to know them and I think that
would be cool, but no question
outside of family members,
Macho Man, like, wrestling
was so culturally relevant
in that period of time and
I'm so anti establishment.
It's so funny, I can
put on a sport at like
one o'clock in the morning,
know nothing about it,
and the second I understand
who's the favorite
and who's the underdog, I'm like my life
depends on the underdog winning.
And Hulk Hogan was so
ridiculously, blindly adored
that I have to go all
Macho Man all the time,
so that's my guy.
- [Male Speaker] Thank you.
- You got it.
Next question.
- [Male Speaker] Hey Gary.
- Hey, bro.
- [Male Speaker] Big fan,
my name is Sebastian, thanks
for taking my question.
- No worries.
- [Male Speaker] First of
all, I convinced my boss
to come see you for the
very first time ever here.
- Awesome.
He's got a rad Koolaid
shirt so that's cool.
- Yeah, that was the
condition of him coming.
Quick question: I'm a CEO
for a chain of escape rooms
and one thing that we
battle back and forth in
is that in every city we
have we don't have a brand,
but we have just city name escape room.
It's done wonders from an SEO perspective
- Yeah, you pander to the Google ecosystem
of the mid 2000's.
- Right, yeah for sure,
and kind of what I go
back and forth is sometimes
I think is it worth it
to scrap it and just start a brand?
- I wouldn't scrap it, I
would start establishing
the brand in parallel.
You know it's funny, my
dad had a liquor store
named Shoppers and Skell
Liquors for 20 years.
There was 20 of them in
Jersey, it was a brand
for liquor stores in Jersey.
When we started wine library dot com,
we didn't change the store's name for
three and a half years.
There was a sign in the
front door when you walked in
that would say wine library dot com,
but we migrated into the brand.
You don't need to feel the pain,
all the loss, the juice that you built up
for the last decade, but I would say
something like, Denver Escape Room
brought to you by the escape hut
and everything, got it?
So, I would transition into it
and rightfully so, you need to transition
to it yesterday, guys, google search
and SEO is in deep shit.
Ten years from today,
everybody in this room
will be doing 80 per
cent of their searching
90 per cent of their searching by voice.
Don't believe me?
I was also telling people they wouldn't
do phone calls anymore
and they would be texting
eight years ago, and you
know that's how you roll now.
It seems crazy, it seems ludicrous
until you see that every
single nine year old
on earth only searches with voice.
Typing search result
is in the early stages
of its demise and if you're built on that,
you rely on that, you
don't have to scrap it,
you have to start building other modes
because you will be in trouble.
- [Male Speaker] Thank you
very much, I appreciate it.
- You got it.
- [Female Speaker] I wanted to ask
what you did before you got started
and if you could go back in time to when
you were my age what tips
would you give yourself?
- You know, it's interesting, Lex,
I think I'm a very big
believer that losing
and adversity is the best thing
that can happen to you.
So, when that question's asked,
where my mind goes is more like,
shit, I wouldn't want to give up
the L's, the losses, or the context.
I mean, you know, if I
went back and, you know,
what would I tell myself
or what did I wish I know,
like, well, I would have bought
Amazon stock for a dollar,
you know, but as far as life,
as you start embarking
on your next chapters,
I think the biggest thing
that people who are young
struggle with is lack of patience,
and I don't think there's a close second.
Everybody is so quick, you know why,
because when you're 22,
you're stuck trying to
prove something to somebody,
whether it's to yourself,
which is really the best,
but for 99 per cent it's
to prove to your parents,
to a buddy, to a friend, like,
it's patience, you know, I had it, um,
but the questions that
you're really asking
is when you value somebody else's opinions
you start taking shortcuts because you're
trying to speed up
proving to somebody else.
When you're in your own shit,
you've got your whole
life to do it, right?
Cool.
- [Female Speaker] Hi
Gary, my name's Michelle.
- Hey Michelle.
- [Female Speaker] I'm
a handmade Etsy seller
- Awesome.
- And I'm fortunate, 20,000
thousand dollars a month
on my handmade goods.
My question is
- By the way, you're working way to slow.
I'm serious doing 240,000 a
month prorated topline revenue
as long as, I know from your vibe
you're not buying dumb shit.
- [Female Speaker] I hand
make it, I buy the wood,
cut the wood packers.
- You're walking into founder's dilemmas,
you're doing cliche shit,
you are months behind
your first employees.
- [Female Speaker] I'm
riding the trend, I get that,
I'm using search terms and ride that.
- No, no, you need to
have other employees.
- [Female Speaker] Oh, yes.
- Like yesterday.
- [Female Speaker] Yes.
- Not trends, you're
keeping too much money,
you need to spend it on people,
you need to stop using your
ego from slowing you down.
- [Female Speaker] I'm trying to get over
not expecting the ten in
hiring and firing ability.
- Or, they may start as an 8.3.
- [Female Speaker] Right.
- Or, to your point, it may be a three.
You've got to get over
that hump, you will lose.
- [Female Speaker]
Right, I'm almost there.
- Good.
- [Female Speaker] My question is,
where do you see Etsy going?
- I think Etsy is a very good place,
you know, I've been fond of
Etsy for a very long time,
but, again, let me answer your question
in a smarter way that helps everybody.
If you are dependent on one platform,
you are in fucking trouble.
- [Female Speaker] I'm
also on Amazon handmade,
so I'm pushing that too.
- Good.
- [Female Speaker] And then my own market.
- Yes.
- [Female Speaker] But
I need employees first
before I can go there.
- Stop, stop.
You know what's crazy
people don't realize,
it's ego that's stopping you.
- [Female Speaker] Yes, yes.
- Good.
Check your fucking ego at
the door and hire somebody.
- [Female Speaker] Thanks
for keeping it real.
- But that's what it is.
But by the way, real
quick, so many people here
that are, let me rephrase.
So many people in the game right now
are so dependent on instagram it scares
the shit out of me.
Please always do what
I do, which is tomorrow
you wake up and it's
gone, what does that mean?
And if it means you're in trouble,
you need to start diversifying yesterday.
Cool, who's next?
- [Male Speaker] Hey
Gary, Milo from Montana.
- How are you?
- [Male Speaker] Good, good.
Uh, I'm the tip of the spear of the
Gary from the spear of Montana by the way.
I'm building a brand, uh,
in a medical cannabis state
where the state prohibits any type of
electronic advertising.
- You don't.
You know, like, when things are
how does wine library ship
wine to Massachusetts?
It doesn't.
Like, legalities are a
friction, so you know,
if you can't do an activity, you don't
and you find ways to figure out
how to do that activity.
So, what about moving?
- [Male Speaker] Uh.
The legalization is coming there
- By the way, I agree.
- [Male Speaker] So we're trying to get
brand and get a plot
because when it does go,
and the big boys all come in
- Well, can you run free information
that has no commerce attached to it?
- [Male Speaker] Yeah.
- That's called branding.
- So you could do it.
- [Male Speaker] As in just bombarding
social media with education.
- Not selling.
Branding, yes, that's exactly right.
You see where I'm going?
- [Male Speaker] Yes.
- You're not going to
run an ad to do a sale,
you're going to make a piece,
you know make a three minute video
about the benefits of or, did you know, or
what's going on.
You're going to market, not sell,
even in the way that you ask it,
it's just an unbelievably
interesting insight.
You're in the mindset of the selling part
that you can't do, but
you're not prohibited
from the branding.
If there's no ask, there's no sell,
so you're establishing brand,
so that when you can layer the ask,
it's just one huge fucking jab.
- [Male Speaker] Right, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Waiting.
- [Male Speaker] Til I can.
- Correct.
Got it?
- [Male Speaker] Got it.
- Cool.
- [Female Speaker] So I have
a problem with my mortgage.
- Yes.
- [Female Speaker] And
I wrote a book called
the simple freedom and I'm branding that,
so now 20 books for real
estate, approaching all that.
- Got it, I know where you're going.
- [Female Speaker] Should I create a
- No.
- [Female Speaker] Okay
- A hundred per cent.
Because it's all encompassing.
- [Female Speaker] Okay.
- Right, and the audience
will go with you, right,
like people are so scared
to show other parts of them.
It's why everybody here who's casual
in their linkedin photo puts themselves
in a suit and tie, like, you can be you.
They will come to you, right
- [Female Speaker] That's
why I wrote another book.
So, I was like, wait, I
could actually do branding
of this book.
- 100 percent.
100 percent.
Yes.
And you can post, by the way,
putting a post that you
went skiing this weekend,
or that you love peanut
butter is a tremendous
off speed pitch as well.
Everybody here's throwing
the same fastball
over and over, eventually
it's gonna get hit.
So, like, mixing it up, like, matters.
- [Female Speaker] I'm seeing that
- Exactly.
Take a picture of some scrambled eggs
and say fucking yummy.
(laughter)
- [Female Speaker] Thank you.
- You got it.
- [Male Speaker] What's going on Gary?
- Hey, brother, how are you?
- [Male Speaker] I am so
excited to talk to you.
You know, first thing, man,
I got you a custom made
battery pack that I think you're
actually going to really like
- Babbin'
I'm super pumped, I need battery packs.
- [Male Speaker] You're
gonna like this one, alright?
- Thank you.
- [Male Speaker] It's got your favorite
football player on it.
- Thank you.
Altun?
- [Male Speaker] Yes.
- Good job.
- [Male Speaker] So I'm
trying to build myself
as an influencer.
- Actually, I just got
pissed at Denver again.
(laughter)
This is true if you're a hardcore
football fan, Altun's
career ended in Denver.
He took a hit in the head
and it was pretty much
the end of his career.
Fuckin' Denver.
You remember?
- [Male Speaker] I'm
trying to build myself
as an influencer.
And I'm trying to build
myself in two different ways,
so obviously dot com, and myself because
I'm trying to brand a
whole entire package.
- Yeah.
- [Male Spekaer] So, I do
videos everyday, all the time.
- Yeah.
- [Male Speaker] And as a new
company, getting the funds,
and trying to make sure we're
spending in the right ways.
I've put a lot of work in it, following
- Good
You mean following people?
- [Male Speaker] Well,
getting followers by talking
- Yep.
Great.
- [Male Speaker] How can I
reach further without having
to spend too much money?
- Do more of it.
I mean, just, news alert
in 2007 to 2011, I spent
fifteen hours a day
talking to people on twitter.
Everyday, go look back at it.
Guys, either you have
your time and work ethic
or you have money.
It's not super complicated.
You have your time,
ambition, and work ethic.
Go to sleep an hour earlier.
Or later, excuse me, like, I don't know.
Work more.
Like, you know, how long has
the business been around?
- [Male Speaker] We started in November
and ever since it's started,
it's just go, go, go, go.
- And his response.
No, and I know exactly
Dude, but you gotta define fast.
My opinion, how old are you?
- [Male Speaker] 42.
- Perfect, I'm 42 as well.
The reason he laughed,
and not in a bad way,
is, I'm telling you guys, it's patience.
Your business is fuckin'
a second old, bro.
Like, I don't want to
ever talk to you again
for another six years and then, and then,
I can't wait.
But I'm telling you, you're going to be
seeing me soon is the biggest reason
I don't think I'm going
to be seeing you soon.
And I'm not trying to razz, I love you,
the Altun thing, we're friends already,
but, I need everybody
to wrap their fuckin'
head around this.
I'm going to make it very clear,
on my childrens' health, I
believe I'm just starting.
On my childrens' health, I
am so early in the process
it will make your head spin.
Cool, nice things are
happening, I understand,
from where I'm going,
what I'm actually up to,
I'm in the first day.
Being seen soon, this and that,
even that question is
completely inappropriate,
coming from love, this early on,
like a lot more organic, like a lot more,
like 20 hours a day.
If you want it that bad,
because the alternatives
you're going to go work somewhere, right?
So to me it's like people are like,
man, but when I tell them 18
hours of community management
searching hashtags, putting out content,
more videos, I have 147 pieces of content
a week, you know, but, like,
I did way more tweets when it was just me
and my phone and it wasn't
Twitter wasn't even mobile, it's was
a desktop and like.
The answer is a lot more.
My biggest piece of
advice is that you think
in ten and twenty and thirty year terms
for real, and not just in a tweet,
not just to me here right now.
Your actions.
Let me just say it one more time
because I know I need
somebody to hear it here.
From the day I started
running that wine business
at 22 years old, until I was 34.
12 years, I worked fifteen hours a day,
six or seven days a
week, in a liquor store.
Twelve years in a row,
fifteen hours a day,
in a liquor store, fifteen hours a day,
had no social life, never paid myself
over 150,000 a year, left at 34
to start with AJ Veener media,
had zero percent
ownership of wine library,
which means I had no collateral
to get a loan or any leverage with a bank
or anything in business and had no money
in my bank account.
I was 34.
I had already built a sixteen
million dollar business
not for myself.
That's called patience.
So when I spit it to you, I'm not coming
from hypocrisy, or a
high horse, I live it.
I'm leaving millions
of dollars on the table
every year for patience.
The answer is a lot more.
- [Male Speaker] Thank you.
- Thank you, you're welcome.
- [Male Speaker] Started
eighteen months ago.
- Awesome.
You got great shirts.
- [Male Speaker] What?
- You got great shirts.
- [Male Speaker] I got one question,
you know, I had a meeting
here earlier today,
talked about Facebook, social media,
we still do a lot of the TV,
Radio, we do a lot of Facebook,
we have a company that
does all that stuff.
Would you recommend
going all to social media
and pulling out of those.
I can't really quantify
anything that we get
from magazines, TV, radio, so,
for the next 24 to 36 months.
- So let's talk about real life.
How much are you spending
across the channels
and how much on each channel?
- [Male Speaker] We probably
spend 20,000 a month.
- And what is
- [Male Speaker] Half is on social media.
- Facebook?
- [Male Speaker] Yeah,
Facebook, uh, Instagram.
- And how's that working?
- [Male Speaker] Great,
it's working great.
Plus we can quantify
it, I know the numbers
- So why are you doing
TV and radio and print?
- [Male Speaker] I thought it was a way
- Build awareness?
- [Male Speaker] Exactly.
- Yeah, so, Facebook's awareness play is
much better than TV and
radio and all that stuff.
You just have to make awareness creative.
So, the 10,000 you're
spending is it kind of like,
is it couponing incentivizing call this,
or is it just videos of how rad it is
that people come?
- [Male Speaker] Exactly.
- My intuition is that I would move
the 10,000 from the
other stuff to Facebook.
- [Male Speaker] Alright, thank you.
- You're welcome, brother, good luck.
Who's next?
People are so infatuated with what's next
they don't focus on
what's actually happening.
Don't worry about voice, don't worry about
augmented reality, don't
worry about block chain,
don't worry about anything.
Your tiny business just started, you know.
Attack Facebook.
I would want most of you to
not even have to do instagram,
though I love it for branding
and being contemporary.
Facebook is so fucking effective
once you figure it out,
and by the way, you can
tweak it eight million ways.
The same way that long tail
search was thing, right?
And creative is the variable,
like the video and the picture
is the punchline, not the ad.
Facebook was great for the math kids
because of all blue letters,
excuse me, google was great
because it was all blue letters.
Facebook is tough because it's pictures
and videos, you actually have
to make a good commercial,
and that's what's fuckin' everybody up.
Focus only on Facebook.
Listen to me, you are so in
outer fuckin' space right now.
I don't want you to say any word ever
again besides Facebook.
(laughter)
Yes.
What the fuck are you
talking about blockchain?
Blockchain is like thirteen years away
from being at scale and impacting
our day to day, like,
if you want to do spec,
etherium, and bitcoin,
doge coin buying, knock yourself out,
but, like, fuckin', buy some
fuckin' Facebook ads, yes.
Thank you.